what's the deal with airplane peanuts
like a little something for the
for the podcast a little protein
there you go a little something for the
podcast that's some onions i had at
lunch what's it like to eat an edible
and xanax do you ever do it together oh
[ __ ] yeah oh it doesn't feel like time
is the edible
the team's here it's like having a
zookeeper you know what i'm saying
[Laughter]
me and billy gardel were flying out of
pittsburgh and we're going up the
escalator where they got that franco
harris catching the ball
and billy goes bro this stromboli's here
through the [ __ ] roof
i said really goes best strum breakfast
storm bullet i've ever had in my life
walk up
two breakfast strombolis and i had i
literally was like
how have i this is now something i will
do every time everyone knows there's
some airports
that are tip top chicago chicago
uh all the italian food oh my god oh i
go there all the time they got the
[ __ ] dog i would delay
oh my god all the time i make rogan go
in there i've made a thousand people go
in there hari
if i fly through chicago and it's a
two-hour delay my dick gets hard
yeah because i go right to that italian
restaurant i put the [ __ ] napkin on
like like i'm vito corleone
and i [ __ ] go bananas oh i love all
that [ __ ] i would call joe the morning
up
and go hey man i can't find my license
are you talking about i ain't flying i
can't find my license
my license was in my hand i just
couldn't leave my apartment
really yeah i was too [ __ ] high and
he's lucky he got a call
i wouldn't even call you know how many
people are still at an airport waiting
for me
there's people still in the airport
calling me going where are you
you said you were leaving the lax at 8
in the morning how long did you run on
together
um five hours and fifty five hours and
33 minutes god bless you i can't even
run for [ __ ] two minutes
yeah so once you turn your head into it
you fall in love with that feeling
yeah it's better than smoking pot oh
that running
when you're running up a hill the first
10 times you're gonna hate it
but once you start doing it and getting
the hang of it
your endoffins you know whatever the
[ __ ] they call them they just set loose
it's
it's it's like harvey weinstein's sperm
it's everywhere i know that you're not
like a like
you don't really care indicator of
sativa but would you smoke a
indicative i'm just taking knickers you
and joe are both like who gives a [ __ ]
it's weed let's smoke it no joe liked
sativa for years
yeah everybody he hung out with in
hollywood was on the sativa
know how my daughter does it oh my that
pool is freezing
i couldn't do that but one in
hollywood's cold but they got a warm
water pool
they got like a 90 degree water pool
that's four feet
you go in there at five in the morning
they got a steam bath they got a sauna
you put a little eucalyptus on the sauna
clean out your nostrils coke rocks fall
out
that was my game back then i'd snort
coke till three
and then jerk off till 4 45 and go to
the y all creepy they'd be like a gay
guy in there laying in the sauna naked
i'm like what am i gonna do with this
oh only gay dudes go in the sauna and
get completely naked
and lay on towels with that dick sign
you're like shave their balls yeah the
russians go in there they sit there
and they drink vodka with a white little
furry hat on yeah at five in the morning
i would go in and i know who was still
out from the night before
because they were going there to pick up
yeah they get freaky and [ __ ]
so the gay guys would always lay like in
the steam bath naked
with their dick out like they were
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
who would lay like this in public they
got no class
but nobody ever bothered me in fact the
gay guys were kind of nice to me they
would come over and say
you're a big guy you sure you're okay
and i would go yeah i mean that dynamite
for me to pass out to come over and put
that dick in my mouth when i'm sleeping
i mean i would you know what i'm saying
yeah lee's been hanging out with this
gay dude that's cool as [ __ ] an open mic
yeah and the guy took a lead on an open
mic and i'm like uh gay bar
legos on this tv screen they had men
[ __ ]
in the back men were [ __ ] i go lee
and he goes yeah everybody was real nice
to me sure
they got you somebody [ __ ] you in the
ass they got a 500 referral free
that's fresh [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying any gay guy could [ __ ] a gay guy
but to convert a guy
yeah that's 10 points that's i always
thought that we were talking me and my
buddy were talking to annie dick one
time you're like
and i don't know if i don't know if andy
dick is gay or not but he was talking
like he was and we're like does
have you ever hooked up with a straight
guy and he's like oh those are the best
those are the best that's
it's that's your challenge anybody could
close a gay guy
but close a regular guy can you imagine
me you're doing both blow we do a couple
lines three in the morning i'm like bert
how long do you want to suck dick for
you like what are you talking about and
i'll convince you
come on bird just give it a little suck
just smell it i wouldn't go see star
wars if you paid me
really i'm not into that [ __ ]
because when i came over from cuba that
[ __ ] i don't like martians i don't
like space
i don't like [ __ ] robots i don't like
none of that [ __ ] and i've never liked
it
ever ever ever i'd watch tv from six in
the morning
to six at night you know why i stopped
at six because star trek came on
once that [ __ ] creepy music came on i
turned that [ __ ] off that's creepy [ __ ]
great
people and all that [ __ ] that's your
that's you know for me it was always
like
i'm cuban i'm a cuban kid i'm just
trying to tv to learn english what's
martian's got to do with it yeah
like i was like i'm not playing this
[ __ ] game you can't just slide that
to life where's my phaser
yeah [ __ ] you i'm old school i still got
hot man i'm still playing
45 000 unread emails yeah you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
45 000 how embarrassing just erase them
you sell merch
no no no oh i only want to focus on
staying up i don't want to worry about
t-shirts
i don't worry about them sending them
back i don't want them sending them
i don't want to put them on the free
luggage on american airlines i don't
want to do another answer
i just want to focus on my stand-up yeah
i want my stand-up to be top-notch
i never want nobody not to come up to me
because they don't have a 25
for my t-shirt if they listen to the
podcast
and they've been listening for the last
five years come over here shake my hand
and [ __ ] give me a hug do you want a
t-shirt you want a t-shirt
go online i'm not carrying t-shirts
across the country
i didn't do this to become a salesman
and while you're on stage you're
thinking about it
i have to go out there between shows
shows are sold out they don't want you
out there
shows are sold out yeah they don't want
to chat i'll tell you
so here you are trying to sell shirts
you got people coming off in the first
show
coming back up for pictures the picture
ain't right
the shirts are medium forget the shirts
and then before you leave you
count them you got 20 shirts by the time
you get them in the mail on monday
you got nine because they stamped up
themselves yeah you [ __ ] the shirt to
20 hours
forget it when i signed a plane that
plane ticket's expensive if i want to
fart
it's bombs away i don't give a [ __ ]
about nobody yeah i just sit i look
straight ahead
and i can i'll adjust my [ __ ] hips so
the fart blows up
and there's a fan on the side if you
ever smoke a vapor pen on a plane
really you'll notice if you take the
window seat
that's where you smoke you can smoke for
an hour really yeah because the
the air is on the bottom test it next
time you have a vapor pen
wear a hooded sweatshirt and take the
pen and put it in your sleeve
and hit it and go like this and watch
how fast the smoke goes
really so when you fart there's no need
to put coffee beans in your ass or
just leave your underwear on it works
like a coffee filter last week in
governor some kid came up to me
and he was this great kid but he asked
me four times after the show
what are you drinking you want to do a
shot i told him 10 times i don't want to
do a shot i'm just going to drink soda
and talk to this guy here
you want to take a picture let's do it
again
do you want to come up man what kind of
shot do you want yeah dog i don't want
to
like they don't get it but i'm not going
to budge at all
yeah like people do not understand that
it's the way i am and you're not gonna i
don't give a [ __ ]
like i don't even like people who drink
at dinner really like when i go to a
restaurant with you and you start
ordering cocktails
it bothers me we came here to eat you
want a drink or somewhere else
go somewhere else take a [ __ ] hike
when i go to drink and snort coke i want
to drink a snort coke
don't play pool i don't want no darts
flying through the [ __ ] air while i'm
trying to play pool
yeah when i drink a snort i don't want
movement
i don't like movement yeah like if right
now me and you brought two chicks here i
don't like a lot of movement
once it says talking and look at that
relax let's call my friend no
don't call your friend cindy because no
ain't nobody else coming here i'll throw
them out
i got a certain amount of coke both
these are sucking thick and that's all
that's going to happen here tonight
i don't like no outsiders like that
scene with germain goodfellas
when she said there was never no
outsiders yeah i grew up there's no
outsiders
yeah when i invite bert to my house
don't bring somebody
yeah come strong don't bring none of
your creepy friends i don't know
i don't want them to see what we're
doing here like i was raised here i'm
saying like yeah
i'm more secretive i don't like movement
when i get when i was snoring you know
why i didn't like people around me when
i was doing coke
because i don't want to hear it yeah i
don't want to hear it start the coke and
shut your mouth and watch tv
i didn't like people if i was doing coke
i didn't like people that messed with
the radio
anything i was [ __ ] anything i was
like we're listening to that song listen
to the whole song no no let's move there
like the tv
once it's six or seven people i take my
cocaine and go home
i like snorlax one or two and women
like if i brought a one i never brought
a woman up to my room that was 50 50.
really yeah like if she's like well i
have a boyfriend listen here's the deal
yeah i got an eight ball of coat you
want to do a lime going up to my room
but i'll tell you what and within an
hour we'll put you to work what does
that mean
it means you're going to be sucking dick
i'm gonna be in your [ __ ] and eating
ass
and they would turn pale yeah and some
of them would walk away
but some of them would come if they came
they knew what time it was
i didn't play don't come here to snore
my coke and tell me your story
you're on the period because i'll throw
you out the window after i would even
tell them you're not on your period oh
you know
okay then you come up because if you
waste my time with that bloody [ __ ]
you come up and you get that bloody
[ __ ] and all i could do a suck titties
and get a [ __ ] i'm gonna be pissed
the [ __ ]
such different people oh no no no i
don't like none of that [ __ ] i don't
want no drama
i would never say that i lo and i
totally go to dinner and
have that's like no i know uh can i get
a i'm gonna start i'm gonna sleep
no i never understood when i go to eat i
gotta eat
you wanna drink go over there and drink
with your buddies it's interesting that
tomorrow will be hanging out and
decorating bikes and and going on
like it's interesting that we're friends
but but we're so different people
i had a friend in high school i loved
him to death i still talked to him one
of my best friends in life
he was always johnny all right
when we were kids when we were kids and
we go to his house
johnny from boi okay yeah i'm the type
of guy you got wine
penny wines yeah give me the [ __ ]
bottle you give me the bottle
and i pour it in this glass and i drink
it yeah no
there's always [ __ ] hold on let me
go get a wine glass
yeah just give me the [ __ ] glass i
gotta wait thing
there's pour the [ __ ] wine in there
what's the difference well the wine
the aromatic listen shut the [ __ ] up
before i smack you just give me the
[ __ ] wine yeah
he would always come down with wine
glasses it would piss me
the [ __ ] off to no end and the girls
would be impressed oh my god shut the
[ __ ] up
drink the wine just shut the [ __ ] up
drink the [ __ ] wine you know
like i'm one of those guys i don't like
no drama and the people i grew up i
remember one time going to dinner with
my friends
i'll never forget this i still talk to
them the hollow ways
roger had just graduated high school the
craziest family i grew up with
yeah that was a bookie mom worked in the
city on a ship like
for a shipping company and it's his 18th
we just graduated high school
and he took us to a fancy restaurant and
i'll never forget the guy comes over
with the thing in front of him
yeah the mr holloway says can i get a
bottle of wine the guy comes over with
the thing in front of him
and he's you know takes the bottle and
he pours a little and he tastes it first
i'll never forget in high school in high
school
my friend looked again just give me the
[ __ ] wine
the guy's face turned pale really i just
gave me the one i don't want no show
yeah you don't have to taste it just
gonna take a [ __ ] night give me the
one
like we all froze at the table
like i grew up with people like that
like one time we were at a buffet
and some fat chick was eating ribs and i
kept looking at my friend roger
and he was eating but he kept looking at
it and he would look at it and he would
get mad he'd look at it finally
i saw him put the fork down and he threw
the napkin down he went up to the
chicken he goes let me ask you a
question
because he kept eating all the spare
ribs
there was this place that gave you half
a spare rib yeah and she was taking
all of them and she was dipping her fat
little fingers in the sparabs and
putting them back
and my friend like two weeks after the
incident with the [ __ ] wine guy
yeah he went up to this chicken and goes
let me ask you a question
before you eat that wing before you eat
that rib
do me a favor go to the bathroom look at
your ass
and ask yourself do i really need this
rib
i'll never forget we turned purple yeah
the people i grew up with
were very like we don't like chick
chowder yeah there's no chick like my
wife she would have got killed
really my friends would have stabbed
them that's so funny what terry
is a sweetheart yeah but she's so
someone that tries to do chitchat
i'm deaf yeah don't tweet your channel
if you got something to say say it don't
be chit chattering yeah
i don't like that uh sitcom mentality
like little jokes
my friends would have killed them yeah
my friends would have stabbed her
they didn't like that either you get in
the car with them shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
know